l'état
[Applaudissements]
marie philip poulin c'est la femme des
grands moments à sotchi en plus du but
égalisateur c'est elle qui en
prolongation et ce qui est le but qu'ils
procurent médaille d'or olympique au
canada
aux jeux de vancouver en 2010 mais les
filets n'a que 18 ans pourtant c'est
elle qui marque le seul but de la
rencontre pour donner la victoire aux
canadiennes 2 à 0 sur les amériques
depuis mes premiers jeux olympiques à
vancouver c'est sûr que j'ai grandi
c'est non seulement gratton 12 ans qui
m'attendent personne aussi mon rôle a
changé
je me sens beaucoup plus confortable
être ci a parlé un petit peu plus et
cherche pas la fille qui parle plus de
ses deux plus ni d un rang par exemple
son dévouement son ardeur son leadership
sont tellement reconnu que c'est elle
maintenant qui porte le c de capitaine
sur son maillot jaune de leader je pense
que je pense beaucoup à coeur puis je
veux que les gens sachent crise très
forte pour moi le départ assez de
pouvoir les payer
conso regarde concentrent à elles qu'on
suppose qu'on s'inspire à chaque jour
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour pouvoir accompli notre
rêve à la fin
ce rêve de petite fille d'être une
championne de hockey elle n'aurait
jamais pu le réaliser sans sa famille
dans sa beauce natale jusqu'à l'âge de
15 ans pour trouver de la compétition à
son niveau et la jouer avec les garçons
ça a dépassé pour me paraît abriter sa
marche papauté est ce le fait ils m'ont
toujours poussé pour toujours nous fait
réaliser que de travailler fort d'avoir
trahi que tout est possible
son prochain défi mené l'équipe
canadienne à une cinquième médaille d'or
olympique de suite
la motivation est là chaque match aller
à la même heure c'est la plus grosse aux
dettes alors c'est ça la paroisse
disparue tellement fort et une carrière
4 à castres en équipe ce que c'est
fantastique
marie josée turcotte radio canada
montréal